the mask mandates lifted for for
transportation and we flew down in masks
and when we came back to the airport
last saturday in the bahamas the airport
in the bahamas was still saying masks
required
okay well it's unfortunate
uh and we um
as i was ahead of you guys on the jetway
that's the word for it right the jetway
is the walk yeah on the jet way and
there was space between me and the
people in front of me so i'm sort of all
alone like walking down the jet way and
there was a stewardess ahead of me
without a mask on and we haven't
traveled much in the last years we've
traveled some and i haven't seen anyone
without a mask on a plane forever
and the people
it looked like the people who were just
disappearing around the corner in front
of me who i didn't get a good look at
still had their masks on i hadn't taken
them off but as i got closer to her i
sort of did like can i take this off
and she just beamed she was so happy she
said yes take it off we were free we
could do this
and i was like awesome like
we got someone who's actually really
enthusiastic about this and on a
different flight we had we had someone
who wasn't enthusiastic about it and you
know they made a point of saying
basically don't judge
you know you're allowed to judge when
everyone has to wear them but now that
you don't have to wear them don't judge
everyone has their own decisions to make
like
fine i guess
but
uh
i will say that i ran into
i ran into because i looked for it
this piece
that's wrong hold on zach don't don't do
this yet um
um
this piece yes now you can show
in washington post the headline for
which is justice department to appeal
mass mandate ruling if cdc says it's
needed the department said it would
defer to the cdc's assessment of health
conditions before filing any appeal
so if i may have my screen back here
there's a line in this article
that
is the abrupt end of the mandate left
little time for airports federal
agencies such as the transportation
security administration which was
charged with enforcing the mandate and
transit systems to prepare
my first response was
are you kidding me like
little time to prepare for the lifting
of a mandate people can just take off
their masks and that's not so hard stop
mandating stop mandating it right and
then you know a couple paragraphs into
the piece they're talking about signage
and like okay sure they're gonna have to
change up the signage again like first
off just invest in a bunch of removable
stickers that say you know masks option
i'll just slap them on all the signs but
whatever i'm glad i'm not in charge of
this
but i
okay signage is
kind of an issue but seriously that's
the best argument they're coming up with
well but this happened so fast but then
as we're so we ended up with a layover
in dallas
and
get off the plane in dallas and no one's
wearing masks of course in the dallas
airport but there's still all the signs
are up still all the signs are up that
say mask are mandatory and no one's
wearing masks because they don't have to
because the signs are out of date
and the happy thought that i had
which may be exactly why
you know wapo on behalf of the
transportation security administration
and airports and federal agencies and
all are concerned here
is that people walking around in open
defiance of the signage
because they actually know the science
is out of date may make them more ash
negative may make them more likely to
say hey you know what actually i don't
need to comply this isn't compliance
is last week's news and now that i've
seen what not compliance looks like
maybe i'm more likely to resist bad
orders going forward yeah uh it's it
that is a kind of a happy thought on the
other hand
the whole point is we've got
captured governance right what it wants
us to do i don't want us to do right
it's up to something and i don't want to
comply on the other hand i don't want a
world of people who are not compliant i
want us to have you know
really high quality light-handed
regulation no more than is necessary to
accomplish the job and done in a way
that it is you know interferes as little
as possible with freedoms of really any
kind to leave people as free to do what
they would choose to do as possible
right that's the ideal
which means that at the point that you
have an
non-captured
government you don't want people
instinctively thinking whatever it wants
me to do i want to do the opposite you
want people thinking oh that makes sense
i'm actually reminded
um maybe summer of 2020
maybe a little later than that i was in
a
text conversation with a friend of ours
from grad school who's been living in
sweden for a very long time
and at that point a lot of people were
like what is sweden doing what is going
on there and then as it turns out sweden
had an effective approach
and i asked our friend like what
kind of what were they thinking like it
didn't
early on when the you know the us and
the rest of the weird world
uh were were putting really strict uh
strict
requirements in place for people sweden
was doing quite the opposite and it
seemed really not what most people who
have at least like me like a cartoon
version of what sweden might do in their
head seemed like the last thing i would
have expected them to do
and she said our friend jen said
well uh
the people of sweden
in her experience actually really do
have a good relationship with their
government because the government does
not hand down dictates very often
and the government doesn't do that very
often
such that
the goodwill of the people is so intact
that if they ever find that they have to
there will be
jennifer's um position was nearly 100
um positive response like okay if the
government is actually telling us now
that we have to do this then then we
should do this but that's because they
reserve it that they don't they they
don't act quickly they don't act
stupidly and sure there will be mistakes
but they err on the side of
not imposing restrictions and lockdowns
and such on people they prefer that
error which preserves the goodwill of
the people and the relationship between
the people and the government to the
opposite era which is what most of the
rest of the weird world engaged in yeah
it's sort of a second order value right
that we you know we think in terms of
preventing disease or failing to prevent
disease or you know things like that but
there's this other question which is the
integrity of the system that is trying
to protect you from disease
that is actually fundamental and you
ought to move very cautiously so as to
not burn its credibility which is what
they've now done in multiple directions
by flip-flopping on everything is you
know frankly people like us have
embarrassed them into acknowledging
things or courts have forced them right
to lift you know mandates they
apparently did not have the
authority to impose yep but you know if
we can connect these two things
we've got an authoritarian
force that wants to mandate all kinds of
things it has no business mandating and
in many cases that you know even
somebody with a passing knowledge of the
facts can tell don't make any sense
right a mask mandate well if you
mandated n95 masks then maybe your
mandate is about
something epidemiological but if your
point is cover your mouth with cloth or
whatever we now know that that doesn't
make any sense right your mandate is not
about epidemiology it's about symbolism
so that's a a horrifying abuse of
authority but we need something with
authority something that actually gives
a damn
to
frankly engage in the treaty making and
the alteration of the processes that we
have in order that you know our
grandchildren can actually emerge onto a
beach and not see a sea of flotsam right
that so the point is the authority it's
not like the need for it has gone
anywhere but it's just being used for
all the wrong things indeed
[Music]